Will happen.
The Joe Rogan experience,
do you think the meek will inherit,
inherit the earth?
You think if that was a prophecy that they would be talking about technologists,
they would be talking about like the people that run Twitter and Google and
Facebook and the Internet tech people,
which is,
if you think about like the amount of money that Facebook has,
the amount of money that youtube has.
So like these,
these enormously influential tech companies.
Even Amazon,
right?
Yeah.
Like who,
who are they?
Who are they?
These are nerds.
They're nerds or super aggressive and they're very thoughtful.
Nerves are very competitive nerds.
So I don't consider them the meek,
I think.
I think who's the mate?
So I think the mic,
the,
the philosophy behind that,
and I,
and I think the United States also works on this premise in a sense is the
American dream.
So what keeps the masses from rising up and taking the money from people who die
the have nots from taking money from the haves and especially when the halves,
you know,
are,
are rather slim in number in comparison to the large proportion of the
population necessarily.
That's $500 in the bank.
Well,
what's great about the United States,
what's always worked about the United States we use,
we don't have these,
the French revolution in this country is because the American dream is about
potential.
There is a potential,
I may not have money now,
but I may and I will because I know I will because I'm an optimist.
I will be in the 1% eventually I got an idea,
bro.
I'm telling you that's a great idea and people need that hope.
Will you take that hope away?
You take the ability,
you take the idea that there's no way I can ever isteam out of my condition.
You better be careful.
That's what,
that's,
that's so potential.
The potential to be better,
the potential to be wealthier.
That.
Think about how all of us,
a lot of us as we're,
as we get older for doing this with them equal,
inherit the earth man.
I think it's in that era that people that aren't creating war was probably the
people that were left over.
No,
I think it's a Wacky,
a pizza.
No,
I think it's,
I think it's a way of getting people to at least live with the fact that I'm a
surf.
I'm a peasant.
I have no way to steam out of my condition,
but at least I have the afterlife.
At least I know that if I live and I suffer well and I suffer quietly and I
suffer with dignity,
there will be a reward after this.
What is the conventional definition or the conventional meaning to that
statement?
The meek will inherit the earth.
Like what or how to scholars interpret that?
Well,
religious,
right,
right.
But I mean how do they,
how do they interpret that?
Like what?
What is,
I think it's in the same vein as,
it's harder for a camel to pastor the,
an eye of a needle than a rich man to enter the Kingdom of heaven.
So,
so you know that the famous story where when Christ said,
did you want to follow me to the rich guy?
He said,
give up all your money in the rich guy turn hung his head and walked away and he
said,
poor guy,
it's so hard for,
for the rich to get to give up their life of privilege is very difficult.
Do you think Jesus was a real person?
Historically?
I think there was probably a rabbi named Jesus of Nazareth,
Nazareth.
That's what,
that's what that seems to be the conclusion among a lot of historians.
And he was a radical rabbi.
He was a radical man cause he's simplified Judaism is really what he was.
He was simplifying Judaism to say,
look,
you know,
you could follow the book of Leviticus and all the rituals it takes to become a
good Jew,
which is there's a certain way to quarter a calf and there's a certain way,
certain things you can eat and you have to bathe and you have to do all these
rituals,
and he said,
way too complicated.
We're never going to spread the word this way.
He said,
just make it simple.
Do it.
Rabbi Hillel said in the Old Testament,
do onto others as you'd have them do onto you and hold only one.
God is your God.
You know the father so that we're all of the idea of a model of a,
of a monolithic God is that there's a,
there's one father,
we're all brothers and sisters.
That way we're all have the same moral worth that way.
I can't judge you that way.
I don't know what you're worth.
Only God does.
I Dunno.
I Dunno where you have,
I don't know what your value is.
You're a human being.
I can't quantify that.
I think.
I think that's a beautiful thing.
I think we all benefit from that religious and that Judeo Christian idea whether
we know it or not.
And if you want to replace that,
my only issue with atheists is if you want to try to replace that irrational
idea,
that irrational idea that we're all the same moral worth.
Cause you can't prove it.
But if you mathematically or biologically,
but what are you gonna replace that with?
Rationality.
You want to try,
you want to,
you want to run a law society on rationality.
You can't do that.
Well if that's the most dangerous idea in the works,
this is still the most dangerous idea in the world because ethics have to be
predicated.
There's gotta be bedrock [inaudible] idea in the world.
Well cause let me give you an example.
It's very rational mathematically to suggest that anybody who is mentally
handicapped is draining resources from our gifted children.
And I'm telling you now in a lot of science history would have who live in
abundance.
It's around new people to take care of the people that are handicapped.
Cause a button says no always last and you can't predict abundance.
And a lot of times there is here right now.
Not really.
Not for a lot of people.
It'd be,
it'd be very easy to justify.
If you are just prayed to the god of rationality,
it'd be very easy to justify it.
And people have done this in history,
which is what I worry about.
Sure.
Hey,
let's get rid of all the people that are draining our resources because they're
not,
they're hopeless anyway.
People on breathing machines,
people who are severely retarded,
whatever,
they are severely handicapped.
Um,
they're draining resource.
I know you love him,
but listen,
we need this money for over here.
You're in a hospital,
you're taking money,
the very old,
the very enforced.
So you think we need religion to keep you from taking people off life support?
Well,
I,
I will say that I think religion and specifically the Judeo Christian ethic,
and I include Islam in that.
Um,
and by the way,
I mean Buddhism is,
it talks about the sacredness of the ascension being these,
these religions are there because,
and I think we benefit from it.
I think that all of us,
I mean where does our justice system is predicated?
It's predicated on the idea that all men are created equal.
We benefit from it,
but there's also real problems with it.
Of course,
real problems with any idea,
but be careful in what you,
but what do you take it away.
Stand is why you think you can't be replaced with logic and reason because logic
and reason has pitfalls,
but you're cause there's nothing logical.
Hold on.
You see,
assuming that logic and reason doesn't also have compassion.
So like you,
you wouldn't have compassion for the people that are mentally handicapped.
Oh it does.
It does.
It's too fickle.
What I'm trying to say is this,
there's something very irrational and very religious about the idea that all men
are created equal.
That we hold these truths to be self evident that all men are created equal.
Right.
And Yuval Harari talks about this brilliantly in his book,
which is that you cannot prove mathematically or biologically that,
that the idea that all men are created equal because that seasons are the new
book sapiens is,
is real.
Right?
So,
so because we're not,
again,
Lebron James,
if he's standing next to me isn't,
we're not equally as my chocolate avatar.
Right.
So,
but we inherently know that our humanness,
our uh,
human s you're not equal physically.
He's a super athlete.
But I'm funny or I have my own gifts to suck.
Yeah.
If he went on stage and murdered.
But there are a few things like Eddie Murphy 2.0 there are people that are
better,
but w w but I won't suck though.
Yes,
he was Lebron James and he was funnier than you.
Well,
he's not a bad actor.
I'll tell you that much.
Imagine if he was really funny.
Like if you couldn't follow him,
that's when I give them my girl.
He imagine that though I would present him with my girl.
Six foot what?
1186 nine six nine six foot,
two 65 bill.
Like a god faster than everybody in stronger than amazing.
And again,
orders on stage at the store
and when you hit the mic,
you have to go like this to get the Mike.
That's right.
Bring it down to you because you have to go on after him.
And that's when I say to him,
he's got it in the mic stand.
It's fucking seven feet in the air.
Yeah.
And I go,
Mr Mr. James,
I'd like to be a traveling concubine.
I'm probably not your ties and want that.
I'm not your type.
No,
you're useless.
I'll take culinary.
I'll take Connor classes.
Let me Cook for,
you know he's got people that shut the fuck up.
They carry the bag.
Polish your shoes.
They're too annoying,
man.
What are you going to do?
You gonna Stare at his dick off connect.
Ask them questions about what a man he is.
This is weird.
What do you squat?
Leave him alone.
Okay,
I'll just be in Nicholson.
Write better jokes.
It's just,
sir,
I'd like to be a gimp.
That would be so embarrassing.
Like if a guy was that good at basketball,
but then it was like a natural at comedy there,
they're all started murdering in harmony.
Like,
or like a fighter like wood.
If Terrence Crawford Tyler to be the funniest fucking dude in the world.
American.
Imagine.
You know,
and he not just fucks people up in the ring,
but then Terrance Crawford starts doing sets the comedy store and murdering and
he's got a Netflix special and he's murdering and you're like,
no.
Oh,
give him,
he goes so good at these things.
I don't know man.
But listen,
there are people that are better at everything sometimes.
I mean there are,
well there's def look,
but,
but we,
Ilan Musk is a good example of that.
How many fucking things can that guy do at once,
but at the same time,
what I'm saying is that you can't quantify human being because you don't know
what their potential is and you don't know where they're strong.
Like if Lebron James Murders on stage,
he's better than you following me.
He's better than you at everything.
Fucking Bert following you.
You've got to follow him.
He's gonna murder and then the king has left the building lasers.
You gotta drop the Mike and walk away.
Yeah,
they have problem and then you've got to go on.
It can't be that good at two things,
right?
I mean who says least sides or how much do you put it?
[inaudible] two things.
Like three times.
As much as let's listen to me.
What if he puts the kind of effort that he puts into getting good at basketball
and he couldn't go to at stand up different muscle.
Yeah.
One muscles.
Lazy.
One muscle doesn't really write and work and like for the amount of hours that
we work on our craft versus the amount of basketball player has to practice
different.
Listen.
Oh,
he's smart.
This is Blake Griffin.
He's been trying to do stand up in the off season.
Last couple of years more.
When he was living in La,
he got traded to Detroit now,
so it's a little bit harder for them probably,
but doing good.
He's good.
Yeah.
I mean from what I've heard from,
I've heard people that have seen videos of it is there you go motherfucker.
Correct.
Yep.
So he can look at six 10 guy doesn't care.
It's a long road.
We'll see in 10 years.
Can work though some if he does it.
Look what I'm saying is like you take a guy who has the kind of discipline and
work ethic that an athlete does at the highest level of the game.
Yeah.
Apply that standup comic.
I bet they'll get further than a lot of us.